[Music]
try Most Valuable Player including last
season LeBron James with his usual
three-game theatrics the first reigning
League MVP to change team since Moses
Malone did a 1982 golf in Philadelphia
the officiating pool Dan Crawford County
Brothers Brian Forte and the season is
underway as the Celtics control Rush on
Rondo put a move on Garnett
Anthony recovered shot clock to one
James yes
LeBron James with his first field goal
as a member of the Miami Heat off Rondo
here's Rondo using his feet
[Applause]
Rondo with a ball fake kicks it out
Pierce for three
Rondo finds Allen
Marshawn Rondo working his magic here
Pierce inbounds Rondo four assists and a
field goal that's called Ray Allen
and there's low scoring first quarter
Marv Albert Steve Kerr bizarre Mike
Fratello here's Baby Davis Marcus
Daniels going through another injury hit
season last year here's Wade and for
Dwayne Wayne mattis's first field goal
oh she felt there was contact
Aslan had knocked away Wade on the
recovery
Pierce putting moves on house going all
the way
space I may have open openings
throughout Texas move and use your
athleticism Jermaine O'Neal got a piece
of it
Robinson with a pretty pass Daniel from
Robinson they often see over me that
wasn't a problem
footsteps
James not able to reach for Nate who was
protecting the ball that's the steal and
here's Robinson again
Dixon both years as you see the steal
from Dwyane Wade
towards the middle of the regular season
they're much more likely to be motivated
and really ready for everything that's
coming their way this year Garnett Kevin
Garnett hitting on his first field goal
attempt into the basket so he put her on
the floor finished it off
not able to handle it
[Applause]
Pierce open for three
missing the chippy
Allen from downtown
tough to tell James yes
final minute first half
Pierce intended for Garnett to steal my
house
who puts it down
five seconds to go Rondo nice lead for
Davis
two seconds left
four Arroyo is open anytime they want to
pass on the ball but he's got to make a
shot here's Alan
[Applause]
Wade fighting boss
so Chris Fox got the Huff the other
thing is everybody knows there's going
to be a rebound so everyone's jumping
into the lane because they know it's
coming off the rim you mean politician
Chris Dudley that's right out of Yale
University oh the turnover the ball back
to the Celtics
shot clock to six another turnover
pierce with the Steal
James with a three-pointer LeBron James
from downtown Champions Kevin has been
in years he's enjoying it he's very
happy and they say the track has
definitely taken a lot of pressure off
everybody in that team
LeBron James controlling going one on
Two And draws the pharaoh to block
before that is a tough ball
that is an incorrect call for James a
7-0 run by Miami and the lead is down to
10 it was once 19.
about a quick release
four back athletic trainer edlas certz
says he's undergoing back spasm so they
have sent him back into the locker room
with a massage therapist they hope he
will return off the school by Garnett
Rondo for Daniels
score
so Eric spolster is going to his bench
James foot three LeBron James heating up
in the second half he now has 19 points
James working with house at the guards
with ilgowskis Haslam and Jones on the
front line
house for three that's a tough angle for
Eddie House
that has good all Lebron in this third
quarter it's
played by Daniels able to slip through
James to the hoop yes
it is down to six third final seconds of
the Court
out of one second Davis coming up short
Pierce hurting his lower back of that
collision with LeBron James and hearing
it from the crowd
Miami down by seven Davis picking up
James Bosh getting it underneath nice
play as he finds Haslam Rondo and
Robinson in the backcourt Pierce up
front with cremate O'Neill and Davis but
Garnett will check in momentarily
he assists
councilman yes
tonight to attack it the same way the
problem is so many new people on Miami
they're not the same defensive team
right now
James Jones who has not been able to
find the range
LeBron James as you mentioned getting
arrest sits down with 25-15 of those
coming in the third quarter Davis
fighting the spot
I think this team is so well put
together as you see way going to the rim
no foul in Boston with another defensive
stop but this bench in Boston I think
has a huge advantage over that of Miami
[Applause]
to be quiet for several weeks after the
procedure is actually excellent news for
his wife first sure love that
Wade with a strong but over to get
inside telford's able to take advantage
when LeBron went out for that brief rest
the other hurt thing we heard doc talk
about before that was the pace that
Boston is playing with Garnett on the
jumper yes but Boston continues to walk
the ball off the floor Kylie has put
Shooters on this roster to surround
LeBron James and Wade
[Applause]
only two and a half remaining
James steps back for three yes just keep
shooting boys
picked up by Allen and fires a three
Dwyane Wade
playing out the clock
[Applause]
here's James strong move by LeBron James
for Boston I thought their energy level
dropped down and as you mentioned how
many times we see Pierce Barnett and
Allen all at the same time there's that
one stretch no energy no scoring
thank you
shot clock to six Allen yes
[Applause]
good timeout remaining Miami in the
penalty Celtics have a foul to give
quick shot put up by weight
fire gave it up
they can't get a shot off house fires
one up
what a sequence defensively by the
Celtics
Oktoberfest yes one of my favorite
holidays mark
[Applause]
the Celtics hang on got a scare in the
second half
Abby led by LeBron James but Boston wins
it
88-280 James finished with 31 points
on 10 of 21 shooting
Dwyane Wade just four for 16 and Chris
Bosh only three of 11 The Big Three
had its problems particularly in the
first half and then LeBron came on in
the second half while Boston getting a
number of excellent contributions Ray
Allen with 20.
Paul Pierce 19 10 and 10 for Kevin
Garnett Shaq played well 9.7 rebounds
and how about Rajon Rondo didn't do it
in the scoring column but 17 assists